[Musique]
arrêtez vous avez bien mangé ça c'est il
ya un très gros bouffons sur la voiture
je sais pas où ça c'est pas à moi tu
voulais qu'ils vont bouffer du sud
ben moi il était comme ça comment vous
avez passé je suis j'ai écrit beaucoup
son chéri gros bouffons m'était conté
malade elle est liée ne pas écrire un
truc tu me prends pas pour on attend
qu'une voiture je suis à martigues
robots pour moi je prends une voiture se
moque ma part c'est plus gros bouffons
battant c'est votre voiture mais qui
écrit chez bahl écrit castaldi 06 30 27
mais j'ai jamais crise et y avait passé
sur la voiture et s'en sortir avec un
stade dicter à l'aigle est surtout fait
draguer ces drogues et sud castaldi
c'est un niveau des chewing gum j'arrive
je me cherche à satisfaire nos
demoiselles ont par contre moi j'ai pas
une bonne soirée donc si tu peux prendre
ta voiture et partir à nice
[Musique]
c'est votre voiture quoi ce n'était pas
comme ça d'un problème tu l'as vu sous
la douche
qu'est ce que mon cul c'était comme ça
vous l'avait amené la voiture
la solution vous monter dans la voiture
mais quand vous êtes dedans
ouais vous voyez pas ce qui a écrit la
fois dedans moi je les garer la voiture
après moi je peux pas rester debout
devant la voiture c'est la
responsabilité
vous l'avez vous vécu j'adore ça ça ne
pèse que j'ai ouvert parce que des gens
comme écrit ça les gens qui ont écrit ça
chauffe c'est pour ça qu'ils ont fait ça
pour la blague
moi je parle gros tu t'y serait le
compte tours alors vas-y part ça c'est
quoi c'est des petits cons avec des
mobiles avec les trottinettes la voiture
et soit nettoyé mais nous on a un
service de lavage mais un poste par la
cub hamel responsable du nettoyage c'est
moi ou corresponsant responsable tu veux
pas parler avec moi puis matin il s'est
pas lavé des voitures depuis 67 villas
jamais laver une voiture donc on a fait
le superviseur c'est un visage tu veux
qu'on appelle de ses voeux le
superviseur on va apprécier
j'ai appelé super bizarre tu seigneur
story au masculin service nettoyage chez
moi j'ai une journée nerfs dossier
oui je m'en fous c'est quoi ça tu veux
acheter 10 écrits gros beauf ou au
niveau de la cuisse qui seront valables
acteurs ses 51 dit tu l'as vu jeudi qui
es tu réponds montcuq et ça fait une
blague
est ce que ça fait là là tout de suite
maintenant enlever les écritures ça nous
aidera pas et un public lui est donnée
comme ça mais dès que je ne sais pas je
suis rentré par un monte j'ai traversé
je vais pas vous raconter bouche c'est
quoi ton premier rôle on one est mohamed
on va passer d'une solution il connaît
des carrossiers mois mais on va te
l'écart aussi au placard aussi j'en
côtoie trop faire des métaux par leur
formidable aventure je connais à 47
verges qui me tient jusqu'en 1/4 aussi
jeter tiges par paul d'ici ce temps que
la voiture soit nettoyée je connais un
carrossier c'est le meilleur la place
devant pas les coûts tuccaro série
s'appelle un coot mohamed calme-toi j'ai
terminé un carrossier le meilleur
carrossier de paris cyril hanouna
meilleur carrossier départ et vous
obtiendrez toi c'est une grande joie
[Musique]
martin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec cyril manouba couture